[Music]
you know when I was a kid every summer
my father would take me and my brother
to Cooperstown to go to the Baseball
Hall of Fame so recently it was a Big
Thrill to get to meet some of these Hall
of Famers who it turns out are real
people they're
actual they're human men that play the
sport so I got to meet them and we
filmed it so why don't you watch it
while I
listen this is Aussie the smooth Smith
yeah can we make a new nickname for you
go ahead the smooth the smooth you want
see the smooth so I am not a sports fan
what is a good way for a non sports fan
to enjoy a baseball game drink a lot of
beer drink a lot lot of beer black out
who cares who's up fall down fall down
try to pick up a girl yeah I believe
Miss America's here have you got it have
you laid your papers on I haven't seen
her yet sorry I'm nervous why are you
nervous pretty well I know a little bit
about you cuz I did some research but
the thing that makes me most most
excited is that you were on The Simpsons
that's right you are a 15 time Allstar
what's cooler that or being on The
Simpsons well I have to say that it's uh
it's cooler being on The
Simpsons you have a board game night at
your house don't you I bet you make aan
hot chop Wednesday Wednesday nights you
say that in Jess but I'm going to be
there with sorry under my arm okay well
you're
welcome you're a fun time I want to go
to your log cabin and make Hooch are we
on the couch now yeah we could do that
want how's your what's your relationship
like with your mother has anyone ever
told you you look like soda Pinsky no
who's that soda Pinsky what the heck is
[Applause]
that he's a video game boxer oh I have
no clue man I have inadequacy issues
that I never never fully you know was
able to to get out right always another
at bat always another champion it's
never good enough for
her it's okay I just going to be loved
man my brother and my father are the
hugest fans of baseball they are going
to be so mad that I'm talking to you
right now well tell them I said High I
will we can call them from your house
while we're playing playing that's right
Scrabble Scrabble I love to play uh Uno
you're a big Uno guy play UNO draw for
man I'm the best I'm the best in the
business really oh
yeah aie
Smith God I want to play Uno with Aussie
Smith